هذه الايام يظهر الاوروبيون التفاؤلا بملء
خزاناتهم للشتاء المقبل فاسعار الغاز
الطبيعي تشهد تراجعا الا ان تحذيرات اطلقت
من كبار المصدرين في الخليج ومن خبراء في
مجال الطاقه لاوروبا من ان القادم قد يكون
اسوا من عن امكانيه استغناء اوروبا تماما
عن واردات الغاز الطبيعي من روسيا ومدى
تاثر روسيا نفسها بالوضع الراهن
تم توقيع اول عقود الغاز بين الاتحاد
السوفيتي واوروبا الغربيه عام 69 وقد بدا
تدفق الغاز منذ ذلك الحين
[موسيقى]
تمر معظمها عبر اوكرانيا كدوله مرور
رئيسيه تمتلك اوكرانيا احد اكثر انظمه
خطوط انابيب الغاز تكاملا ويمكنها عمل
الكثير باستخدام خطوط الانابيب هذه عندما
اعلنت اوكرانيا الاستقلال منذ ذلك الحين
بدات الصراعات بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
وروسيا
لا يمكنني تفسير اعتماد اوروبا ليس اوروبا
باكملها ولكن لماذا اعتقدوا انه من
المناسب الاعتماد على مصدر واحد لسد
احتياجاتهم من الطاقه
طلب على الغاز بشكل كبير جدا
وروسيا قريبه الى اوروبا لسوء الحظ
الاتحاد الاوروبي حاليا هو في ثنائيه صعبه
لماذا لانهم يقومون بانتهااج سياسات اهداف
صفريه من حيث الانبعاثات في 2040 و200 وفي
الان ذاته هم لديهم مشاكل تتعلق بتامين
الغاز الطبيعي المسال وهذا يشكل ازمه
كبيره وربما قد تكون هناك ازمه طاقه في
الشتاء القادم
2025 تملك روسيا اكبر احتياطي للغاز في
العالم بنحو 19.9%
وبرزت روسيا في عام 2021
كاكبر مورد للغاز الطبيعي الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
ويبلغ معدل رسوم عبور الغاز الروسي
لاوكرانيا دولارين و66
مقابل كل مليون متر مكعب لكل 100 كيلومتر
وهي التكلفه الاعلى اوروبيه بطبيعه الحال
قررت روسيا تنويع طرق توصيل الغاز لذلك
ولدت فكره بناء خطوط الغاز بدون دول عبور
والتي تصل مباشره الى السوق الاوروبيه
يمتد خط النورد ستريم واحد المزدوج بطول
1224 كيلومترا عبر بحر البلطيق من روسيا
الى المانيا ولديه القدره على نقل 55
مليار متر مكعب من الغاز سنويا الى دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي اوروبا المعتمده اعتماد
كلي شبه كلي على الغاز الروسي ما كان
عندها تنوع في المصادر
الاعتماد على سوق واحد خطر جدا
في مايو 2022 اغلقت شركه غاز بروم خطا
انابيب الغازي امان ثم اوقف الضخ الغازي
عبر خط غاز النورد ستريم واحد قبل ان
يتعرض لاحقا لتفجيرات مما وضع اوروبا امام
مازق لتعويض الغاز الروسي
تعرف روسيا اهميه الغاز الطبيعي جيدا
واستخدامه كسلاح
الحقيقيه هي اننا اذا لم نتمكن من الحصول
على امدادات كافيه من الغاز من مصادر اخرى
فسيكون لدينا شتاء بارد وستصبح الامور
اكثر صعوبه كل ما يجب لمواجهه الوضع
الحالي هذا سيؤثر كثيرا على الاقتصاد
العالمي لان اوروبا جزء كبير من هذا
الاقتصاد لذلك العالم العربي
يتاثر بسرعه ما تتاثر به دول الاقتصاديه
الكبرى هذه ضربتها اقتصاديه كبيره لنا كما
ان واردات الغاز تمثل جزءا كبيرا من
الميزانيه الفيدراليه التي لا نريد ان
نخسرها المشكله التي لدينا الان هي ان هذا
الشريك غير جدير بالثقه يرفع السلاح
ويستخدم طاقتك اداه ابتزاز ضد الاقتصاد
الاوروبي بهدف تقسيمنا هذا شريك لا نريد
التعامل معه بعد الان
سنشهد المزيد من حرق الفحم وهذا لا يتوافق
مع خطه المناخ الخاصه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
بدات اوروبا في التحول الى الغاز الطبيعي
المسال من الولايات المتحده بدلا من الغاز
الروسي الا ان التكلفه العاليه لا ترجح
كونه بديلا محتملا في المستقبل وهي ذات
العقبه التي تواجه خيار الغاز القطري
والذي تصر الدوحه ان يكون بعقود طويله
الاجل نحن لا نؤمن بالعقود القصير يجب ان
يكون لهم عندهم عقود طويله الاجل
والنهي هذه هي اللي بتخلي التوازن
والاستمراريه الجزائر تزود اوروبا بالغاز
عبر خطوط انابيب الغاز المشكله مع الجزائر
هي مدى قدرتها على زياده الانتاج اذربيجان
اتركستان كلها فيهم طبعا كميات كبيره لكن
مشكلتهم انهم ما يسمى بالدول المسدوده ما
عندهم بحر ما رايناه في الواقع ان الشركاء
حول البحر الابيض المتوسط يعملون معا بشكل
بناء لمساعده اوروبا في تجاوز الازمه لقد
وقعنا على مذكره تفاهم ثلاثيه بين اوروبا
ومصر واسرائيل لجلب الغاز من شرق المتوسط
الى الموانئ المصريه ثم اعاده تصديرها
كغاز مسهل الى اوروبا بالطبع يتجه الغاز
من افريقيا الى اوروبا الان لكن الغاز
القادمه من نيجيريا عليه ان يقطع مسافات
طويله جدا لذلك كلما مرت خطوط الانابيب
عبر بلدان اكثر فانها ستكلف نفقات كبيره
من حيث الاستثمار لا يمكن التعويض عن
الغاز الروسي الناس يجب ان تعرف ان بحدود
20% الان من واردات الاتحاد الاوروبي
واوكرانيا تاتي من روسيا 20% لا يمكن
التعويض عنها باي شكل من الاشكال